معركه الموانئ في حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا
هذا ما يبدو عليه الامر خلال اليومين
الماضيين تضرب القوات الروسيه مواقع
للقوات الاوكرانيه في مقاطعه اوديس جنوبيه
البلاد تلك مقاطعه تحوي اهم موانى
اوكرانيا حتى خلال الحرب الحاليه من هناك
تتحرك الحبوب الاوكرانيه نحو العالم وفق
اتفاق تصدير الحبوب تقول رئاسه الاوكرانيه
ان الضربات الروسيه استهدفت عمدا محطات
الحبوب لتدمير امكانيه شحن الحبوب
الاوكرانيه تتهم كييف روسيا بتعمد خلق
ازمه جوع عالميه ومحاوله اضعاف الحلفاء
يذهب وزير الزراعه الاوكراني نحو التفاصيل
اكثر ليقول ان تلك الضربات دمرت 60 الف طن
من الحبوب بناء على هذه الاتهامات تطالب
كييف بتجديد العقوبات على روسيا ومن
يساعدها في الالتفاف على العقوبات
المفروضه الضربات الروسيه جاءت بعد ساعات
من ضربات اوكرانيه استهدفت مواقع عسكريه
الروسيه في شبه جزيره القرم يقول الروس ان
الاوكرانيين استهدفوا ميناء سيفيستوبول
الاستراتيجي مقر اسطول البحر الاسود
الروسي في شبه الجزيره التي تسيطر عليها
روسيا منذ 2014 وتعتبرها اوكرانيا جزءا من
اراضيها لا يمكن التنازل عنه بالتقادم
هكذا تحولت الموانئ على الشواطئ الشماليه
للبحر الاسود الى عنوان معركه جديده في
حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا فهل من بديل تبدو
الطرق البريه بديلا ممكلا لرحله الحبوب
الاوكرانيه عبر اوروبا الى العالم بدل
الرحله البحريه المختصره الى اسطنبول
ومنها الى العالم لكن الرحله البريه هذه
ستكون اطول من حيث المسافه والمده الزمنيه
لوصول الحبوب بالاضافه الى الكميات التي
تحملها السفن من الحبوب وتحتاج الى شاحنات
اكثر بكثير لحمل نفس الكميه عبر البر
معركه الموانئ تتخذ شكل عض الاصابع الان
لكن اثارها تتجاوز حدود
[موسيقى]